all right does this look like a secure
border to you fox cameras in arizona
capturing camouflage migrants climbing
over a border wall using a rope to repel
down and then running into the open
desert i might point out that nada one
was caught by border patrol
uh this is a sign of the times and we're
seeing this more often and doesn't art
del cuedo no the national border patrol
council vice president are it's amazing
but as you say and keep reminding me
this is more common than most folks
think what's going on
it definitely is look we're looking at
over half a million godaways this fiscal
year so far you're seeing the video of
those that climbed over and got away
that that you add that to 165
000 that have gotten away in tucson
sector it being the most got aways del
rio's got over 150 000 got aways
i mean it's just it's the sign of the
times and it's happening because this
administration created that magnet by
moving agents from one area to another
when the cartels are constantly looking
at what's happening they're looking at
the traffic the cartels are doing this
this administration has created the
magnet and it's there's no end in sight
because no one's taking it serious right
now you know obviously they're
emboldened enough fully aware cameras
showing their every move to do what they
do and i'm thinking of what the vice
president said a couple of days ago that
the border's secure
you're the expert i'm not but that
doesn't look like a secure border to me
you know and you don't need an expert to
tell you the american public has seen
the video they know what's going on
at this point
i'm at a loss for words and and i'm not
at a loss for words often but i don't
know what the the vice president is even
thinking by saying that and to keep a
straight face and to actually believe
you're going to fool the american public
with lies about this
they've created the mess the cartels and
the drug uh individuals are the ones
that are flourishing from this and who's
suffering the united states you're
looking at these groups that have gotten
away and you've got to look back during
the obama administration when we had so
many of those unaccompanied juveniles
that came across where are they no one
knows where they're at now the same
thing is going to happen many years from
now with these individuals that have
come across and gotten away and it's
going to happen with the individuals
that this administration has released in
the united states by bringing back catch
and release to this country and real
quickly on those being bust to points
north and sanctuary cities uh
we really have no way to keep track of
them no matter where uh where they go
right
there's there's really no way that
they're going to keep track of them to
be honest they'll go to their initial
court hearings but then afterwards when
they realize they're going to get sent
back to their country they'll disappear
into the shadows like president obama
said at the time the shadows of humanity
and just you'll never hear from them
again
so this just gets worse
it gets worse and it's going to have to
take real political uh you know
individuals that really care about the
country that are in office to turn this
around to stop it right now but
unfortunately we're seeing no end in
sights the flood hey gates the
floodgates have been opened and no one's
doing anything about it at this time
incredible art el cueto thank you art is
with the national border patrol council
the vice president there he has been
warning about this and reminding uh
anyone who's anyone that look we've got
a problem here and right now it's out of
control i went on brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now